bonjour nouvelle émission de la
rédaction de tv fil 78 d'une émission
politique à un an avant le premier tour
des élections municipales de mars 2014
que fait plaisir de présenter les goûts
où il ferait bon soir comme moi tous les
mois ou tous les mois
tous les mois à 26 minutes 26 minutes
pour faire le point sur ces élections
municipales et en plateau de nombreux
invités
ce qu'ils feront à l'actualité politique
locale et ce soir effectivement première
émission et pour cela nous avons invité
les leaders des principales forces
politiques présentes dans le département
et je rappelle que pour faire ce premier
choix nous sommes appuyés sur les
résultats des dernières élections
législatives alors en plateau avec nous
sophie primas bonsoir vous êtes
sénatrice ump des yvelines vous a été
missionné par valérie pécresse la
président de l'ump départementale pour
proposer des investitures et déceler si
je peux dire des nouveaux talents
s'il explique rsa dans quelques instants
également stéphane olivié bonsoir à vous
vous êtes pour le parti socialiste
secrétaire fédéral chargé des élections
et à vos côtés françois simeoni pour le
front national bonsoir à vous numéro
deux au niveau départemental secrétaire
départementale adjointe et puis enfin
olivier paréja pour europe écologie les
meilleurs bonsoir donc un bon 4 et pour
rappel de tout d'abord le déroulé de
cette émission nous allons parler de
l'organisation de ces élections en tant
que tel et puis nous aborderons ensuite
un thème de politique locale le droit de
vote des étrangers vous nous direz
notamment la ligne de vos partis
respectifs pour ou contre alors d'abord
l'organisation les élections municipales
cédant 1 en mars 2014
on va faire un tour de table rapide vous
en êtes où est ce que vous avez commencé
à recenser vos candidats es ce que vous
avez vu un petit peu les lille prenable
comment ça se passe en premier en effet
nous sommes dans le le temps du travail
sur les municipales et nous sommes en
train de répertorier d'analyser avec les
maires en place l'ensemble c'est des
situations locales qu'elles soient dans
les grandes villes ou dans les petites
villes
et puis d'accueillir aussi un certain
nombre de candidatures qui viennent
spontanément se présenter afin de
pouvoir organiser en fait l'ensemble de
nos équipes sur le terrain dans tout les
types de ville comment vous organisez
pour le parti socialiste par exemple ça
c'est plutôt mois d'octobre pour les
désignations des l'étape de liaison des
têtes de liste ce sera le 10 octobre en
ouganda délais même si dans certaines
villes les équipes sont se mettent déjà
en place
en tout cas on travaille actuellement
imminente une phase de bilan de choix
dans les équipes on est des
municipalités plupart dont on est en
responsabilité dans le bilan de ce qu'on
a pu faire soit au delà on était dans
l'opposition va devoir le bilan de la
municipalité en place et on va ensuite à
partir de ce bilan
travailler sur un projet à présenter aux
citoyens donc à l'automne pour vous je
les bannis pour l'ump mais ça sera plus
rapide entre guillemets c'est plutôt
juillet sera plus fin juin début juillet
on aura 90 % je pense d investiture
front national alors comment ça se passe
le front national rassemblement bleu
marine a déjà investi des candidatures
on a déjà une commission d'investiture
actuellement il ya quatre villes des
acquis ont leur tête de liste il ya il
encourt mantes-la-ville sartrouville
versailles
que ce soit par exemple et on est en
train de réfléchir également sur
d'autres notre commune des yvelines
saint germain en laye rambouillet
notamment et d'autres petites communes
comment vous faites votre choix
justement des communes où le front
national le rassemblement bleu assez
facilement sur sur deux deux critères
principaux notre représentation dans la
commune et les résultats que marine à
fait pu faire aux présidentielles et que
le candidat a fait aux législatives qui
ont suivi pour rhdp colliger les verts
on est dans une phase où il ya un
fourmillement on est en train d'essayer
de regarder le bilan des municipalités
qu'on soit dans la majorité qu'on soit
dans l'opposition et essayer de voir
quelles sont les possibilités en
essayant d'avoir une démarche de
rassembler au plus large de ne pas
rester sur les personnels politiques
habituels mais d'ouvrir vers vraiment à
la société civile aux associations qui
sont qui sont proches de nous de nos
idées soient même volonté aussi d'ouvrir
aux associations la société ciné je me
tourne vers ses ennemis pour le front
national
dans le cas du rassemblement bleu marine
ce rassemblement est censé donc être
accueillir d'autres partis mais
également des personnalités géologie de
l'art collard en études donc des
personnalités qui arrivent spontanément
de la société civile on va tout de suite
regardé un premier reportage
catherine va faire un premier point on
parler un petit peu de l'organisation
des partis politiques on va voir
quelques noms quelques noms qui
ressortent des candidats qui sont déjà
connus d'autres qui ne se présenteront
pas petit à rappelle à tout juste un an
des élections
ce n'est un secret pour personne la
protégée de valérie pécresse
aurore bergé 26 ans devrait se présenter
à magny les hameaux
elle pourrait dévoiler sa liste pour
l'ump avant les vacances de cet été
l'ancien ministre devrait jouer un rôle
important dans sa campagne face à elle
le socialiste bertrand guillon tout
nouveau maire suite au départ de jacques
los dioses un duel qui sera observé
puisque c'est dans cette ville que
pourrait se jouer la couleur politique
de l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines autres villes et trois autres
candidats joséphine coleman ce berger
ump bernard ansart ps et bruno tabary
modem à plaisir celle qui a succédé à
joël regnault devra conserver la ville à
droite alors qu'au dernier
native à la gauche était arrivé en tête
devant david douillet des mères en poste
qui ne font pas de secret de leur
volonté à remettre leur mandat en jeu
michel laugier divers droite à montigny
le bretonneux françois de lignées ps à
guyancourt
alexis piette ump à voisins le
bretonneux et jean michel fourgous
également ump à elancourt ce dernier a
déjà distribué sur sa commune un tract
présentant son bilan pas candidat jean
françois raynal conseiller général ump
secrétaire départemental de sa formation
après avoir annoncé son intention de se
présenter en janvier dernier pour
récupérer la ville de poissy au
socialiste frédérik bernard qui lui
devrait repartir devant les électeurs il
fait aujourd'hui machine arrière
il laisse la voie libre à à karl olive
lui aussi conseiller général ump ancien
journaliste et qui dispose de nombreux
réseaux dans le monde sportif en
particulier celui du football candidat
ou pas candidat sauf surprise il ne sera
en tout cas pas tête de liste le
socialiste benoît hamon
le ministre en charge de l'économie
sociale et solidaire et de la
consommation pourrait être intéressé
pour rejoindre l'équipe de guy malandain
trappe
seulement la prochaine loi sur le
non-cumul des mandats pour l en empêcher
à moins d'un remaniement ministériel
dans les prochains mois aussi en
réflexion henry pailleux maire ump de
coignières en poste depuis 1986 il
prendra sa décision durant l'été et puis
philippe lavaud ancien maire de saint
cyr l'école démissionnaire en 2006 il se
verrait bien faire de l'ombre à bernard
de bain ump qui lui a déjà annoncé son
intention de se représenter
ce sera sans doute l'une des têtes
d'affiché de l'ue dei dans les yvelines
aziz senni a fait part de son intention
de se présenter à mantes-la-jolie
entrepreneurs issus du quartier du val
fourré il s'est fait connaître par son
ouvrage l'ascenseur social est en panne
j'ai pris l'escalier il est aussi en
charge des questions de sécurité
d'immigration et des cultes pour lui d i
2 jean louis borloo et bien sûr nos
invités vont réagir à ces différentes
rumeurs ou non est ce que on a vu juste
est ce que tout ce qui se dit justement
est plutôt vrai j'ajuste juste pour pour
continuer pour être complet sur
versailles françois de mazières à divers
droite devrait être candidat face au
socialiste marc dias gamma pour le coup
c'est pas encore décidé et non de ce qui
se dit donc c'est vraiment
et françois sémiologie par contre cinq
candidats sachent aussi d'elle après
surprise c'est fait non mais c'est au
centre
je ne sais pas du tout qui sera retenu
il faudra peut-être lui dis moi docteur
iso tassart mois d'octobre pour la joie
des lillois parrainons effectivement
plaisir vous avez cité ce sera bernard
ansart gouvernance c'est vraiment une
personne voilà énorme surprise et
l'office a pas de surprise était quand
même autoproclamé
oui mais tous les socialistes de plaisir
souhaite que ce soit lui le candidat
donc il faudrait vraiment d'accord
qu'ils changent d'avis tout cet été mais
voilà donc aucun il ya aucun suspense ce
sera lui voilà donc ça mais dans la
plupart des villes effectivement par
rapport aux rumeurs reportage combien de
d'écouteurs c'est concerne l'ump par
exemple sur la ville de magny les
hameaux
laurent berger on en parle souvent on la
voit beaucoup elle est venue s'installer
dans cette commune on se doute pourquoi
il est venu s'installer dans cette
commune ya quelques années est ce
qu'elle sera tête de liste elle sera
candidate je ne sais pas si elle sera
tête de liste encore je suis encore dans
la perspective d'attendre les
investitures sur la fin du mois de juin
début du mois de juillet comme je vous
le disais c'est valable aussi pour
aurore elle jouera un rôle essentiel
soit dix sept villes de magny les
hameaux elle fait partie des jeunes ump
que nous souhaitons promouvoir que nous
souhaitons pousser pour les prochaines
années donc elle jouera un rôle
essentiel mais je ne sais pas si elle
sera tête de liste encore à date basque
s'investit la manière d'un hameau des
villes prenant s'il sent que c'est un
enjeu important manif souci du monde si
les autres communes reste car leur
couleur l'agglomération peut
effectivement tombé dans la pièce phare
cela d'un hors jeu extrêmement important
donc je pense que on y mettra tous les
moyens je m'en coller des bois
on pouvait croire il ya six ans que
d'ailleurs le résultat avait quand même
été assez largement en faveur de jacques
l'oeil aux je suis pour ma part très
très confiants sur le résultat sur sur
magny les hameaux je pense que la
transition entre jacques lolliot des
bernat et bertrand guillon s'est
vraiment bien passé ça mais plutôt un
cas exemplaire pour ce qui pourrait se
passer dans d'autres communes et on peut
avoir cela des inquiétudes ou regarder
des virées plus intentions manifestées
par la droite entre guillemets dans un
chenil est par exemple réagir sur sur
magny les hameaux
comment vous voyez ça écologie les verts
à ce que vous êtes rapprocher du parti
socialiste pour alors pour l'instant
constitué si c'est vrai à peu près dans
tout le département où prend des
contacts avec les différents partis
politiques on essaye de s'ouvrir comme
je le disais tout à l'heure et à cet
effet par exemple on a organisé des
journées des séminaires le samedi ouvert
à tous nos sympathisants et même plus
largement pour par exemple faire le
bilan de dd mandat que nous avions
pendant la dernière mandature pour faire
des formations sur la communication sur
la prise de parole en public
faire de la formation également aussi
sur à quoi sert un conseil municipal
comment fonctionne un budget municipal
quel est le rôle d'une d'une
intercommunalité
quelles sont les règles qui changent à
ce propos là donc ça c'est des choses
qu'on organise pour essayer de drainer
au maximum donc il ya des contacts avec
les partis politiques pour l'instant on
n'a absolument pas de ligne définie
d'alliance systématiques ou de nos
alliances systématique ou bien sûr et
partis politiques avec lesquelles on
discute c'est la gauche donc tous les
partis qui m'ont appelé à voter françois
hollande au second tour des
présidentielles et toutes les toutes les
opportunités d'autonomie de d'allianz se
sont ouvertes dans la mesure où on
arrive à faire avancer le projet qui est
le projet que porte europe ecologie les
verts
et puisqu'on parle d'aller ans du côté
du front national aucune alliance avec
aucune formation
écoutez vous parce qu'on avait parlé par
le passé d'alliance de rapprochement
avec l'ump certains voulaient elles
voulaient pas c'était il ya quelques
quelques temps au nom des législatives
c'est pas si loin
aujourd'hui vous avez pu constater que
un petit peu absent dans le reportage et
la présentation vous venez de faire pas
d'élu front national qui ont ils sont
présentés qui ont parlé donc c'est un
petit peu anormal quand même avec dans
une démocratie où marine le pen a fait
presque 20 % des suffrages ne pas être
représenté au comunale dans les geôles
et de conseil dans des conseils c'est
bien normal donc j'espère que ça va être
réparée avec les élections à venir
une question sur sur trappe on était sur
la 11e circonscription sont un peu en
avance benoît hamon sur la liste de guy
malandain le maire sortant je sais quand
vous confirmer ou non c'est pas encore
décidé est-ce que vous proclamez la
présence de sandrine grand bang qui est
ce que je me dis malandain qui fera
salies c'est une éventualité oui une
question aussi sur poissy directement
détenues par un maire socialiste jacques
bernard il est dit on très menacée en
tout cas par karl olive qu'est le
candidat ump jean françois raynal s'est
retiré de la course pour laisser quinze
années tout seul est ce que ça vous fait
peur c'est une des villes où le résultat
sera absent doute le plus serré on sait
qu'on a pris possible aux dernières
municipales que des fois en six ans
c'est plus compliqué de mettre sa marque
on a vu les résultats aux élections avec
un candidat mais c'est pas y compris je
suis pas sûr que l'ump choisi le
candidat le plus sérieux pour qu'on nous
vole je crois que ça donne c'est renard
frédérik bernard
a aussi un bilan maintenant à défendre
il a sa personnalité je pense qu'il
passe bien auprès des pics acier non
c'est c'est une ville où on pense quand
même même si ce les choses ne sont pas
évidentes on devrait quand même le
conserver juste avant de s'intéresser au
centre à la formation de l'udps et au
modem également j'aimerais votre
réaction à tous les deux pour europe
ecologie les verts et pour le front
national on parle forcément des deux
partis principaux qui s'avance peut-être
le plus pendant ces élections pour
autant quelle place pour vos parties
pour vos formations pendant ces
élections municipales c'est toujours
plus difficile d'exister ou non je ne
pense pas je pense que les français donc
il y avait les conséquences de
l'élection de françois hollande avec eux
son échec vis-à-vis de ses promesses et
l'austérité qui est en train de qu'il
est en train d'imposer
quant à madame prime 1 qui propose pour
l'ump justement une autre voie je pense
que ça sera l'austérité aussi en ce qui
concerne europe ecologie les verts
belle idée ça va pas être nécessairement
de conquérir les grandes villes du
département
effectivement il ya trois villes qui
sont aujourd'hui qu'ils ont des mers
europe écologie verts on a un certain
nombre d'adjoints et de conseillers
municipaux dans les yvelines donc la
présence d'europe écologie les verts est
pas et aujourd'hui pas négligeable mais
l'idée ça va être principalement de
peser sur les programmes et au premier
tour au second tour que certains
marqueurs qui sont ceux de l'écologie
qui sont ce qui intéresse les gens
les les élections municipales reste
encore des élections qui qui motive les
français et qui sont pas nécessairement
qu'ils n'ont pas le même discrédit que
le personnel politique nationale on va
dire on voi enquête par exemple du
cevipof qui a eu est publié en décembre
ou en janvier qui montraient encore que
dans les élus c'est quand même encore le
maire et les conseillers municipaux qui
sont les plus appréciés de la population
donc c'est important que nous
écologistes nous puissions à ce
niveau-là faire passer nos messages
parce que c'est ce que j'attends d'eux
un certain nombre de personnes dans les
yvelines c'est tout à fait une élection
de proximité on va parler maintenant une
autre formation sens très très large à
parler de lui dès qu'il vient donc de se
regrouper dans le département alors nous
avons leur avons demandé à ses élus udi
quel était leur stratégie
et nous sommes aussi allés du côté du
modem pour avoir leurs réactions
reportage lui dei l'union des démocrates
et indépendants se met en ordre de
marche
regroupement officiels de plusieurs
formations politiques du centre sous
l'impulsion du parti radical offrir une
autre vision des choses une autre vision
politique comme ce fut le cas dans le
passé avec des partis comme comme l'udf
même si aujourd'hui on n'a rien à voir
avec la partie regroupements comme l'udf
mais on a évidemment des des prises
opposition et des visions différentes
parties qui existent aujourd'hui que ce
soit le parti à droite tous les partis à
gauchy comment lui dei se positionnera
pour les municipales de mars 2014
le rassemblement présentera des listes
communes ont 20 à l'intérieur de chacune
nos formations puisque ces formations
continuent à exister
elle nous dit c'est pas une dissolution
des formations continues à l'intérieur
de chaque formation
on va sélectionner un certain nombre de
candidats alors candidat à la mairie ou
candidate sur une liste 1 qui sera menée
par d'autres éventuellement et puis
ensuite on se retrouvera entre nous et
entre nous on fera la sélection du
meilleur qui portera le sigle dei le
mouvement fera t-il alliance avec l'ump
présenté comme un partenaire naturel
on est aux prémices de la discussion
avec l'ump ça se passe très bien
moi je rencontrais souvent gérard
larcher ou valérie pécresse on a de
bonnes relations ils sont tout à fait
d'accord pour considérer qu on a
d'excellents élus d'excellentes
personnalité de notre côté il ya des
élus et qu'ils ont on travaille très
bien l'ump évidemment donc charge à nous
trouver une alliance intelligente et
qu'ils soient gagnantes pour les
prochaines élections
répondre à de vraies situations locales
pour être en capacité de fournir les
projets que les gens attendent donc ce
sera vrai là où il ya déjà des
implantations pour le reste l'enjeu
c'est peut être déclenché une bagarre
qui n'a pas de sens c'est d'être présent
avec une volonté de faire des choses pas
d'aller à la bagarre pour le plaisir du
côté du modem pas question pour l'heure
d'intégrer l'ue dei
on souhaite garder son autonomie tout en
se rapprochant des partis du centre au
cas par cas
on va essayer au cas par cas de
travailler avec eux on aura pas d'accord
départemental en tout cas ni avec lui
des signé avec le centre iris sony avec
le nouveau centre où toutes les
mouvances qui font partie de lui dédie
aujourd'hui mais on essaiera travailler
ponctuellement avec avec avec ces
parties là j'attends de voir vraiment ce
que lui d y obtiendra de l'ump dans ce
département qui est quand même assez
adroite pour pour dire quelque chose va
encore une fois je lui dis n'existe pas
vraiment on verra au mois d'avril quand
ils seront constitués ce qu'ils seront
en capacité de faire dans le département
pour le modem 30 à 35 candidats sont
déjà identifiés comme bruno tabary sur
la ville de plaisir
le nouveau rendez vous politique
mensuelle de téléphiles se poursuit
toujours avec et stéphane olivié du
parti socialiste sophie primas de l'ump
françois simeoni du front national et
olivier paréja d'europe écologie les
verts chaque mois nous reviendrons
également avec nos invités sur
l'actualité ce soir nous mettons
l'accent sur le droit de vote des
étrangers c'était une promesse de
campagne de françois hollande son
engagement numéro 50 je cite
j'accorderai le droit de vote aux
élections locales aux étrangers ray 10
ans ready résidant légalement en france
depuis cinq ans vous allez me dire ce
que vous en pensez chacun pour l'instant
le point avec la rédaction julie rocha
soir est pour ce reportage
promesse historique de la gauche élargir
le droit de vote aux étrangers pour les
élections locales était la proposition
numéro 82 françois mitterrand reprise
par françois hollande cette promesse
présidentielle devrait se concrétiser en
une loi constitutionnelle a déjà été
adoptée en première lecture au sénat en
décembre 2011
mais le texte est depuis en attente à
l'assemblée nationale à partir du moment
où ils vivent vivement depuis assez
longtemps sur le territoire français ils
ont droit de voter de 6 ans quand même
représentatif d'une grande majorité jeu
deux personnes dans les deux lieux de
vos communautés donc ils ont quand même
le droit et un mot à dire on paye notre
loyer ont subi la loi français pourquoi
pas admirer les élections municipales
même pour la lessive ou pour élire un
président de la république dans un pays
il faut être de nationalité de cette de
ce pays
malgré que moi je suis d'origine
étrangère ça je le soutiens et je enfin
j'en suis d'accord mais tout ce qui au
niveau communal au niveau municipal
régional et où je pense que les
habitants des quartiers les habitants de
la municipalité de la région
ils sont plus à même de délire la
solution pourrait être le concept de
réciprocité né au maroc les étrangers
par exemple les français expatriés qui
sont installées au maroc
passé par le moment a cassé en droit de
vote une idée partagée par le maire de
montigny le bretonneux
il faut aussi tenir compte de l'opinion
des français et ne pas les diviser sur
des sujets qui ne les intéressent pas
mais il peut y avoir d'autres d'autres
solutions aussi on peut y aller de
manière progressive tout simplement dans
la réciprocité
ça serait pas mal déjà que les français
qui sont qui vivent dans un pays
étranger puisse aussi voter dans le pays
étranger
à l'heure actuelle les lui ni mantin
évoque la naturalisation des étrangers
afin d'obtenir les droits liés par
contre du côté de guyancourt c'est une
évidence les étrangers devraient pouvoir
voter aux élections locales et même
pouvoir s'y présenter comme candidat je
pense que des personnes qui vivent sur
un territoire qui vivent dans une
commune depuis plusieurs années qu'ils
payent des impôts des personnes dont les
enfants partagent nos écoles des
personnes qui participent à la vie
locale
ça serait quand même une reconnaissance
et ce serait une intégration
supplémentaires le député yvelinois jean
philippe mallet évoque les mêmes valeurs
en faveur de l'égalité
c'est important que pour les élections
locales les étrangers puissent voter ils
travaillent ils contribuent à la
richesse de notre pays et donc il est
important qu'ils puissent qu'ils
puissent voter
c'est un problème de 2
de dignité la gauche est déterminé à
obtenir la majorité nécessaire des trois
cinquièmes au congrès pour réformer la
constitution
reste à convaincre une trentaine de
parlementaires on va donc commencer par
cette question simple favorable ou non
au droit de vote des étrangers aux
élections locales on va commencer par un
parti socialiste devant préciser une
chose le droit de vote des étrangers
existe déjà en france c'est pour les
ressortissants de l'union européenne
et ils ont comme la proposition de
françois hollande c'est élargir à
l'ensemble des d'être inauguré
terzian de résidence en france moi je
pense que c'est tout simplement une
mesure de justice et de bon sens aider
des personnes qui sont donc en france
depuis longtemps qui participent à la
vie locale jeudi il s'agit de ses très
cadré il s'agit de désigner des conseils
municipaux qui ne pourront pas être
adjoint passé exactement le les mêmes
modalités que celles pour les
ressortissants européens et je pense ce
serait vraiment une mesure d'
intégration aussi c'est une mesure qui
est aussi très attendue par certains de
nos compatriotes dont les parents sont
étrangers qui verrait ça d'un très bon
oeil et juste pour préciser mais on sait
qui on est dans la situation il ya
effectivement blocage puisque il faut
les 3 avril il faudrait une trentaine de
parlementaires de droite votent cette
mesure tout cas nous parti socialiste
des yvelines nous allons mener une
campagne sur le terrain pour défendre
cette idée du droit de vote des
étrangers
vous voyez un peu sourire de toute façon
pas du tout étonnant tant moi je suis
tout à fait opposé cette proposition de
loi
j'entendais mon collègue parler
d'égalité mais ça serait des citoyens
qui auraient le droit de voter qui
aurait le droit d'être conseiller
municipal me leurre pas de juin donc
l'égalité c'est pas ça l'égalité c'est
soit en fait on est français on adhère
aux valeurs de notre pays
on adhère aux principes on adhère à la
nationalité dans son entièreté et on en
a les droits et les devoirs et dans ce
cadre là on peut voter je ne suis pas du
tout choquée par le fait que dans
intérieur la communauté européenne on
puisse effectivement participer aux
élections locales puisqu'il ya
effectivement réciprocité ce n'est pas
le cas dans la grande majorité des
autres pays et puis moi je ne veux pas
d'une égalité bancal
l'égalité des droits mais à toutes les
sauces mais là en l'occurrence ce serait
une pauvre égalité certains pays où
c'est possible en irlande la finlande
les résidents étrangers au maroc mais je
n'y suis pas favorable
en tout cas pour la france et je ne
ferai pas partie des trente
parlementaires qui seraient susceptibles
de changer
rim a commencé je remercie votre
tribunal d'avoir fait cette déclaration
puisque effectivement je ne fait pas
doute pour le front national que nous
sommes intimement persuadés que la
nationalité il y un team m'en lirez aux
droits de vote
donc il est hors de question qu'on
l'accepté en ce projet il répare et cela
pour europe ecologie les verts nous
sommes clairement pour cette mesure là
je pense que il faut absolument pas
confondre citoyenneté et nationalité
amalgamer les deux on arrive
nécessairement à des blocages ce qu'on
est en train de vivre ce qui a été dit à
l'instant sur le plateau on peut y très
bien imaginer que les résidents qui
payent des impôts qui y vivent qui
travaillent qui payent les cotisations
sociales etc
dans une ville puisse élire les
conseillers municipaux participer à la
vie de la cité
sans pour autant parler de nationalité
on est vraiment sur deux registres
différents et il le mélange et ne fait
qu'un amalgame et pardon les choses et
on ne peut pas avancer il faut
absolument y arriver la proposition ça a
été rappelé dans votre reportage date de
françois mitterrand moi je votais même
pas encore à ce moment là il serait
temps qu'on le fasse un jour ajouter si
ce problème de petites choses j'ajoute
une chose c'est que les populations
étrangères sont parfaitement à impliquer
dans la vie communale on a à coeur dans
toutes les villes d'ailleurs qu'elle
soit de gauche ou de droite à intégrer
l'ensemble des communautés c'est comme
ça qu'on arrive à équilibrer la vie dans
une ville et à éviter les effets de
ghettoïsation donc les populations
étrangères ne sont pas du tout étrangère
ni à la vie citoyenne puisque l on
vienne dans les rues dans les réunions
de quartier elles viennent dans les
maisons quartier ce sont elles qui anime
leur quartier elle participe à la vie
citoyenne comme cela et c'est très bien
allons plus loin allant plus loin et
pour conclure sur le front national a
voté jeudi ou frau parti socialiste se
méfier parce que les changements
sociétaux qui l'a imposé récemment qui
veut imposer la société française ne
sont pas de nature à plaire aux sociétés
traditionnelles d'origine africaine ou
maghrébine
donc il arrive que d'amendé surprise des
surprises en suivra tout ça en tout cas
il se représenterait pour lui c'est pas
merci en tout cas vous 4 d'avoir
participé à sept ce premier rendez-vous
municipales 2014 proposé par la
rédaction prochaine grosse truite ce
sera le samedi 13 avril à 10 heures et
n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez revoir
cette émission sur notre site internet
vous pouvez aussi laisser vos
commentaires ou échanger directement
avec nous via les réseaux sociaux via
twitter excellente continuation de
programmes sur notre antenne